- Everything I just said
sounds inspirational.
It's actually practical.
(drums hitting)
It's not rah rah shit,
like, "you can do it."
- Right.
- It's, "how are you choosing
to look at your life?"
And then if you practically
realize opportunity,
and be grateful for
whatever the fuck you have,
'cause somebody's always got it worse,
well then, it starts getting interesting.
(mood music)
- [Both] Aaay!
- [Narrator] You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(mood music)
- DJ Will.
- Such a pleasure.
How are you?
- It's a pleasure, finally.
- Havin' a good day.
- An honor.
- How are you, my man?
- Good to meet you.
- Respect, bro.
- It's a real pleasure.
- 'Sup, bro?
- It's ridiculous.
- DJ Mr Famous.
- It's a real pleasure.
Nice to meet you.
Hello.
- Hi, I'm Natashi.
Natashi, how are you?
- Good.
- That's good, everyone.
- I had already been
following you for a while.
- Yeah, we all follow you.
- Thank you so much.
- I almost answering the
questions that people ask you,
'cause I've been feeling like,
I know what you're gonna say.
(group laughing)
- Yep.
- I almost feel stupid to ask questions,
'cause I'm like--
- Well, sometimes it's,
what I like about it still,
to your point, I'm so consistent.
Sometimes, people make fun of me of light,
"you say the same shit."
I'm like, "that's the fuckin' point."
- Mhmm.
- Yeah.
- People when they leave
comments or say to me,
"you say the same shit,"
think they're dissin' me.
I'm like, "motherfucker,
that's the point."
- Right, makes sense.
- It's already drilled in my head.
- And then, but where it's nuanced,
and why it's nice to meet people,
is sometimes it can be subtly nuanced.
Everybody's question comes from
a slightly different point.
The big part of what I'm
trying to figure out what to do
is like, back to what I was just saying,
there are 13 to 27 things
that are the things.
Then it's like, "what's up in your life?"
Somebody has a sick mother.
Somebody's trying to
fuckin' rule the world.
They don't care about money.
They want fuckin' fame.
Some people want fame.
Some want legacy.
Some just want their
kid to be proud of them,
'cause they're not proud of their dad.
There's so much shit underneath it,
but the foundation, the shit I'm spitting,
it's fuckin' real.
And then, the other thing
you don't know when you're 15
and a fuckin' knucklehead
is, life is long.
Thank god.
(knocking)
Obviously, tragically.
Sometimes, no, but like--
- For the most part, yeah.
- There's a very high
chance that the four of us
are gonna live for 50 years each longer.
- [Man] Right.
Facts.
- There's a lot to do.
We were parented and
grand-parented by people
who didn't live to 100, but we are.
- [Man] Right.
- So, that's the shit
I'm trying to get people
to think about.
How old are you?
- [DJ Will] 43.
- Right, so like, when we were fuckin' 18,
43 seemed like 1000.
I'm 44.
- Yeah.
(group laughing)
- You know, right?
- You're like, "ew."
- What are you talking about?
I'm still young.
What do you mean?
- But now we're like,
I don't know, I'm 44.
I feel like I got my
whole life in front of me.
- Yeah.
- Obviously, we've been through some shit,
but like, there's a lot to do.
- [DJ Will] For me, I started feeling
the last couple of years,
like damn, I'm old.
Like, is this it?
And then--
- You know what ends up
happening, your game is,
when in something that
has youth culture in it,
you see somebody doing something special
that you're proud of
them, or happy for them,
or envious of them, and they're 19.
You're like, damn.
My whole is like, don't look at them.
Look at the other four billion people
that are 80 doing shit.
Everybody's like, "but Gary,
look at Mark Zuckerberg,
"he's 25," or, "look at
fuckin' Chance the Rapper,
"he already did."
I'm like, what about the
fuckin' eight trillion
fuckin' people that are 80 doing shit
and still haven't broke through?
Why are you looking at the .000000001%
to judge your happiness?
Why don't we look at the fuckin' masses?
- Right.
- Us in this room, us being in America,
we're already winning.
- [Group] Facts.
- Perspective.
- And once you see
gratitude and opportunity,
life is fun.
When you think something
is suppressing you,
it's easier for you to feel suppressed.
Minority, I get it.
That's true.
That's actually true,
but once you get into,
"what am I gonna look at?"
Lotta things are true.
What was true for me, is
I spent the first 20 years
building my parents' business for them.
That was my truth.
Lots of things are true.
Kobe's life was good, and
then it had a tragic end.
There's a lotta truth,
but you get to decide
if you're gonna dwell,
and play prevent defense,
or if you're gonna see opportunity,
and be grateful, and go on offense.
That's what I'm trying
to get people through.
I can sit with anybody.
Show me the richest white male in America,
and he'll cry about some shit,
like, his mom was horrible.
You know what I mean?
- [Group] Yeah, yeah, right, right.
- You pick.
- Everybody have a story.
- Yeah, and then everybody knows somebody
who's got all sorts of
fucked up situations,
and they're happy.
That's called perspective.
- Perspective.
- You're right.
- I know.
Everybody can talk about
somebody who's happier than them
that has it way worse,
and sadder than them
that has it way better, right?
And if that's true, which it
is for everybody if you think,
then that becomes the actual game.
That's what I think about,
and that's what I'm
trying to make popular,
and that's why I think
it's making an impact,
because it leads to a
nice place, you know?
- Great impact.
- Yeah because, I come from
a place that's more zero,
and so, and the way I talk
to people in that spot
is not looking down at them,
and it's not even trying to inspire them.
It's just real.
Everything I just said
sounds inspirational.
It's actually practical.
- Right.
- It's not rah rah shit,
like, "you can do it."
- Right.
It's, "how are you choosing
to look at your life?"
And then if you practically
realize opportunity,
and be grateful for
whatever the fuck you have,
'cause somebody's always got it worse,
well then it starts getting interesting.
- Other than the money,
what's driving you to--
- The best part is, the
money's not driving me at all.
- I see that.
- I could be really really
wealthy if that was my game.
I like the legacy.
I like these moments.
I like people.
I really like people.
- Yeah--
- I got really lucky that
social media came along
where people interaction went to scale,
because the way people look at me now
is just like the way
that they looked at me
when I was a kid in my crew.
I was the nice person.
I was the person that, like,
my high school friends
poppin' up, they're like,
"actually, this makes sense.
"You gave up popularity,
'cause you coulda had it,
"'cause every popular kid liked you,
"because you wanna be
friends with everybody,
"and that cost you in high school,
"but that's who you actually are."
That sports car flex wasn't to say,
"look at me, I put 50 into LeBron.
"Now, it's 200,000.
"That video was, motherfucker,
"I just told you nine
months ago to do this.
"You coulda done it too with one LeBron."
Guess what, 'cause I was
there, when you only have,
not only, when you have
$1000 to spend on somethin',
and it becomes worth 4000,
and you could buy it on eBay,
and sell it on eBay
between April and February,
that shit matters.
- Mmm, yes.
- Yep, absolutely.
- Right? I think all of
us can remember when $1000
was a big fuckin' deal, and the thought
of making a good decision doing something,
and five months later, you have 4000,
that fuckin' resonates to all of us.
- Mhmm.
- Yeah, right.
- I remember that day like yesterday.
(DJ Norie laughing)
Where fuckin' takin' 1000 to
4000, but what do people do?
They go to a casino.
But what do people do?
They bet.
They do dumb shit, and I'm sayin',
that same hustle's out here.
You know basketball players?
Good.
So, it's why I'm confusing,
'cause when I do it, right?
I understand how it can be seen.
I'm just not worried about the judgment.
For every person that DMs me, like,
"you're a fuckin' asshole.
"Who has $50,000 to buy sport cars?"
I'm like, "motherfucker,
you didn't hear what I said.
"This wasn't for you.
"You've decided to look at the perspective
"of coming up with excuses
why you're not winnin'."
Motherfucker had nothin'.
(chest thumping)
(DJ Norie laughing)
There's a lotta people out
there that do have $1000,
who are tryin' to get goin'.
"The system fucks me."
"No it doesn't.
"You know LeBron's the best.
"You know sports cars are comin'.
"I'm givin' it to you for free,
"cause you're following
me on social media.
"Go and buy the fuckin' LeBron.
"You can have 4000, now."
By the way, it's going to 10,000.
- Right, I seen.
- Straight up.
I'm tellin' you right
to your face right now,
if you have $4000 right
now, you can go on eBay,
buy a LeBron, it's 4000, and 6000 in July
when they're in the finals.
Some people are like, "I
don't care about 2000 bucks."
I'm like, "buy 80 of them."
That's 160,000 bucks.
So, what I'm tryin' to do
in a lot of different ways,
is try to teach, but I'm
doing it from an angle
where some people really hear me,
and that's why they're growing,
and some people don't like it,
because they don't wanna do it.
I'm puttin' pressure.
- Yeah, pressure's real.
- I'm puttin' pressure.
I'm pokin', I'm pokin'.
I'm like, "cool, you're more
than welcome to complain."
Nobody gives a fuck
- Give a fuck, yo.
- Nobody cares, man.
And like, when I talk
to African American men,
I wish 100% of every
white person in America
knew what it was like to
get pulled over 13 times
in a year.
It's just something they'll never know.
All my friends in college were black,
but it still wasn't me.
I was in it.
I did get pulled over all those times,
'cause I was in the car,
but even though I knew it,
you don't know it until you're in it,
and you still can't fully
feel it when you're not it.
- Right.
- But it'd be nice to
even know how true it is.
That's what everything is.
So that's example of race issues.
Then there's the example of opportunity.
I wish everybody knew that
had 100 bucks right now,
that if they went garage
saling, to Goodwill,
and the Dollar Store, and worked,
instead of crying about it,
and six months later had 2000.
I wish they could taste it.
- Do certain things.
- 'Cause pride is a lot of
times disguising insecurity.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely right.
You're worried about
somebody seeing you go
to the Dollar Store,
and you're not lookin'.
They'd rather spend 800
bucks they don't have
on some Wetherspoons, than spend 100 bucks
to go to Dollar Store, buy
40 or 50 of these things,
and everyone's laughin' at them.
I just didn't give a fuck.
- Yeah.
- Mhmm.
- The ability to not give a fuck.
- I think that's it.
- Of course that's it.
That's why if you look,
Russian immigrants,
and African Americans are very similar.
They flex for perception,
not truth.
- Right.
- That's real.
- If you didn't see, he used
to go around to garage sales.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's why I do it now.
I do it now, and here's what happens
in the comments on YouTube.
I go in garage sale, and I'll
do it in a couple of months
when it warms up, and I'm
trying to teach people,
so when somebody's like, "six bucks,"
and I'm like, "three bucks."
And the comments, if your
perspective is complaining
and shit's fucked up,
they're like, "fuck this guy.
"You're a fuckin' millionaire.
"The fuck, are you
rippin' these people off."
Right?
On the flipside, I'm getting
the DMs and the comments
from people like, "you taught me.
"Now, I do this.
"Now, I quit this bullshit job.
"Got a different job,
'cause I'm making enough
"on my side hustle of garage
saling, I'm happy now."
I need to be able to
deal with the judgment
of somebody calling me a millionaire
ripping off poor people.
That hurts.
That's not my intent.
I didn't steal it.
- But I still won up.
- I went to a garage sale.
They wanted six bucks.
I offered them three bucks.
They were pumped.
(group laughing)
They were happy.
They were.
I'm there.
I know, they were thrilled.
That's garbage.
They're about to throw that out.
They were pumped, but no, cynicism,
the kid layin' in YouTube watchin'
that YouTube video watchin'
me, who doesn't wanna work.
"Oh, I see how he got ahead.
"He took advantage of people."
Uh uh uh uh uh uh.
"You have an excuse to not work."
- My first perspective
of it was the pride.
I was like, "I don't know how
"he's fuckin'goin' in garage sales"
I'm doin' it fuckin' by myself.
- Bro, bro, the amount
of people that hit me up,
my friend's friends are
like, "yo, you can't do this.
"You look stupid."
And literally, that first day I did it,
the first thing I did
on Instagram Stories,
before I did a YouTube video,
and I DM my friends back.
I was like, "you don't know me.
"You think you know me.
"You know me now.
"This is who I am.
"I'm dirt."
(group laughing)
"I'm dirt.
"You think I'm penthouse.
"I'm dirt."
I'm dirt.
And that's why I think I
resonate in certain pockets,
whether it's the culture, you know?
'Cause I'm dirt.
- [DJ Norie] You understand.
- I definitely understand it.
I lived it.
I was in it.
- [DJ Norie] They don't understand it,
so they don't know how to--
- They don't understand that I'm going
to Chicago this weekend,
and I'm gonna win the Spades Tournament.
(DJ Norie laughing)
But I know.
And that's what people said.
Every time something comes out
that gives people a
little bit of perspective,
it's the same old thing.
They're like, "oh, now I get it."
I'm dirt.
- [Man] I love it.
I'm on it all day long.
- [DJ Norie] But the number one thing
is to invest in yourself
though, at all times.
- The number one thing is to
find happiness on your terms,
and then reinforce it so much
that you can't even hear peoples' opinions
on what you should be doing to be happy.
I did it for so long.
Like, this is perfect.
When this is your report,
like, this is the shit, right?
Like, again, you start hitting the scene,
and everybody sees you, but
if people knew that I was.
Literally, this is my entire high school.
My class rank was 243 out of 254.
I was literally the 11th worst
student in my entire grade.
I'm dirt.
This whole system told me I was a loser,
that I would never amount to nothin'.
We're in the same age group.
There was no entrepreneurship
when we were comin' up.
There was hustle for you guys.
But like, in my world, there
wasn't entrepreneurship.
That wasn't a thing.
You wouldn't start a company.
Go to college, right? How
many times do we hear that?
Go to college, as if it
was the only fuckin' path,
but for me, why I'm at this
place of this young of an age,
is back then I knew.
I'm like, "cool, you keep tellin' me,
"but I'm in my own head.
"I know exactly what I'm doin'.
"I'm gonna be nice to the
nerds, 'cause they're humans.
"I'm gonna sell baseball
cards in the lunch room
"while you all laugh at me,
"'cause I don't give
a fuck what you think.
"I don't need your fuckin' confirmation,
"affirmation, or co-sign."
In my head at 12, I'm like,
"you're gonna want my co-sign."
And now, I'm right.
Practice that.
Practice.
- [DJ Norie] Claiming somethin'.
- And then also, another
thing that I'm really trying
to talk to people about is like,
everybody else sucks, too.
One thing that really worked for me,
and I'm starting to talk about is like,
when I would feel bad, I'm
like, I never envied anybody,
because I would look at somebody.
Somebody's dunking, and I'm like,
barely got my jump shot down.
I'm like, "yeah, but they
suck at, they're not nice."
Or like, to me it's like, "why
are you beating yourself up,
"and putting somebody else on a pedestal?"
They got fuckin' shortcomings, too.
Right?
They're just human.
And then what that does is a weird thing.
Then you start celebrating people,
instead of envying them.
- [DJ Norie] To stop for
a second, in our culture,
that seems like you're a hater.
- [Man] Hatin', right.
- [DJ Norie] So, it's the difference
when you're saying like,
you're not nice, but then in our culture--
- Here's the best.
You'll appreciate this.
Every culture the same.
That's the slang term
we use in that culture.
- Yeah.
- Mhmm.
- My grandma uses that term, too.
She was a white Russian woman.
She had a term for it; jealousy.
You know what I mean?
(group laughing) You know,
in Russian, in Yiddish.
Every culture's got the same shit.
They just use different words.
It's all the same shit.
- [Man] Right.
Just different words.
You just say it better.
(DJ Norie laughing)
That's why it became the lay of the land.
Honestly, on some real shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Hip-hop is rock 'n' roll.
Those were gutter kids, that
were anti-the establishment.
- Right.
- Right? And you can
already see it right now
with sexual preferences,
trans gen, other things.
That's gonna be the next culture.
It's been written.
In 30 years, right?
'Cause now, there's somebody
more suppressed than you.
That's all that happens.
It's always the same.
The kids from the dirt
always win in the end,
if they can keep their mind right.
Most can't, and they feel
the pressure, and they break.
But the small percentage that
realizes it's a strength,
not a weakness.
- They win.
- Yeah, that's why when I make content,
people are confused.
I'm like, talking about rich kids,
and I'm like, "you don't get it."
They've been told they can't
win, so they've already lost.
Their parents are taking
care of everything.
Every time I put out that content,
the whole suppressed comes
at me like, "fuck you."
(DJ Norie laughing)
"I'd rather cry in a Mercedes."
I'm like, "you don't get it."
- [Man] Right.
- Right?
- Just like your boyfriend saying,
"I get it, the cops are bad." Mmmm.
- [DJ Will] Right, they don't get it.
- Well guess what, if
you're not a rich kid,
you don't get it either.
"I understand you want the Mercedes.
"Let me tell you about
the fuckin' deep pain
"that's goin' on when
you're parents in the world,
"and no matter what you accomplish,
"everyone's gonna say it
was your daddy's money.
"You lost."
- [DJ Norie] Right.
- When you start at zero or suppressed,
at least you have a chance to climb out,
and then be on a hierarchy.
You have a hope.
You can be on a pedestal.
You're admired from comin' from it.
When you're in the other way,
you lost before you started.
There's nothin' you can do.
- [DJ Will] That's why a lotta them break.
- And they really break.
- [DJ Will] Right.
- I'm talkin' suicide.
Like, (knocks).
- [Man] Right.
- [Natashi] Mental health.
- Mental health.
It's so funny, and I gotta run.
So much about white privilege.
I think about it a lot,
obviously 'cause I care
about these cultures,
how they mix.
When we get to mental health privilege,
that's gonna be the biggest conversation.
If you are privileged
enough to have self-esteem
through chemicals and
parenting, you've won.
And that's what I'm tryin'
to do for my audience.
I'm trying to be the gap of
building up their self-esteem,
but first you have to be not
entitled and stop complaining.
- [DJ Norie] Stop complaining.
- 'Cause nobody's listening
but another fuckin' loser.
The only person that listens
to somebody complain,
is somebody else that complains.
(group laughing)
And you get into it worse, right?
And you get into one big
dinner of dwell fest.
(DJ Norie laughing)
And everybody leaves unhappy,
and nobody's doing shit about it.
- Nobody give a shit.
- Fellas, that was fun.
- We gotta take a picture.
- We got in it.
We gotta take a picture.
(hip-hop music)